[Music]
I'm David Nutt and I'm a psychiatrist
neuro pharmacologist working in Imperial
College and a lot of my professional
life I've been trying to bring science
to drug policy and this talk is a
combination of about 20 years of
thinking deeply about the nature of the
problems of drugs and drug harms and how
to minimize them and as you'll see from
the title I believe decriminalization is
the way forward and I'll give a little
plug for my new book on the right here
you see the second addition of drugs
without the hot air which goes into the
rationale a in the science behind this
particular talk in much more detail and
importantly all the proceeds of that
book support my charity drug science
this is an image of me being sacked by
the government I used to be the
government's chief drugs advisor and was
sacked in 2009 by Alan Johnson and the
reason I was sacked it was because I was
arguing that current drug policies are
evidence-based and there was a
particular obsession with drugs such as
MDMA and new psychoactive substances and
cannabis to the I think was almost
deliberately producing a smokescreen to
avoid confronting the drugs which are
particularly but still the most damaging
in the UK which are alcohol and tobacco
and that's really shown rather well with
the scales of justice in the bottom left
hand corner and at the time I thought I
was right but I argue that cannabis was
unfairly penalized so subsequently I was
proved right because no lesser authority
than President Obama said so and in a
remarkable speech where he for the first
time admitted that US policy on drugs
was actually had been wrong and that
cannabis should speak um legal at least
be allowed as a medicine
as it is now in over 31 US states and he
said because it's no more dangerous than
alcohol and I would completely agree
with him but it's still illegal under
federal law and it's still illegal in
this country and why is that well it's
because we provide we currently have a
use reduction prohibitionist approach so
I want to talk about some of the terms
which is very important that people
understand the terms were using
criminalization prohibition is the
general way in which drugs which are
illegal are controlled around the world
and basically possession or use of a
drug in some countries in the UK
thankfully is a crime that can be
punished by criminal sanctions including
the death penalty in some countries deep
penalization or decriminalization is
what I'm gonna argue is the right way
forward and this means no criminal
sanctions you can apply civil sanctions
for instance if you catch someone with a
a drug which is decriminalize you can
find them you can withhold their driving
license you can often as they do in
Portugal use what they call dissuasion
processes to help people understand the
harms of using those drugs and but you
don't get a criminal sanction so you
don't drive the criminal underworld
legalization generally is taken to mean
anything from a fully open market where
you can sell any drug to anyone just
rare in the world but I suppose in some
parts of the favelas in South America
most things are available if you want or
it could mean a regulated market like we
have currently with alcohol and tobacco
in Britain where there are age limits
and safety limits so there are those
terms in mind as we go through my talk
so I'm gonna argue the decriminalization
is the right approach for a number of
reasons the first is it avoids the
massive damages that criminalization
produces the second is a
decriminalization is actually
proportionate to the health harms of
drugs
the third is it that it will greatly
facilitate research and clinical
innovation and the fourth is it works we
know from over 40 years of
decriminalization of cannabis and nearly
18 years of decriminalizing or drugs in
Portugal that this approach works so
let's look at the current policy that we
have in Britain well it's a punishment
based policy and the first is it's
biased about the drugs which we control
it's dishonest and therefore immoral we
don't control tobacco we don't control
alcohol but we control other drugs which
I'm gonna argue are actually less
harmful there so this makes it a
peculiarly dishonest and ineffective
policy one of the reasons we have this
peculiarity of almost much you might
call sort of scientific nihilism about
drug policies is there is no definition
either in the UN conventions or in the
UK Drugs Act about what a drug is or who
should say what a drug is and basically
that means that it's left to politicians
to newspapers and the drinks industry to
define what a drug is and of course they
do it not based on harms or risks but
based on political or economic and
benefits so here's a wonderful example
of how the drinks industry alters
people's perceptions as what a drug is
say no to drugs that way you'll have
more time to drink now of course
everyone knows that alcohols a drug but
it isn't controlled as a drug under the
misuse of Drugs Act why not
because historically it's been exempt
why because people like to drink and the
drinks industry has thanks very best to
make sure that people don't understand
the risks of drink and they often
distort the harms of other drugs and try
to minimize the harms of alcohol so my
definition of a drug is here something a
politician once years but now regrets
like a couple of examples in my career
of Jackie Smith a Home Secretary I
locked swords win over the comparative
harms of ecstasy versus horse riding she
said I smoked cannabis
but I didn't enjoy and you think well
why would you bother but maybe you had
to do that to get into the labour party
in Oxford when she was there David
Cameron I did things when young I
shouldn't have we all did and great
thing about David he tended to do drugs
which began with the same letter as his
name see drugs like cannabis and cocaine
so we know there's a strong tradition of
politicians using drugs we've had this
recent example for instance of Michael
Gove having been quite into cocaine
Parks's but he now regrets that and but
he's very glad he wasn't caught and
wasn't imprisoned for it when we're
looking at drugs and drug policy what
are we trying to do well we are trying
most of us will argue to reduce harms
and perhaps the most important
significant harm of a drug is is death
now the latest data we have on the
earths from different drugs on the left
hand side you see tobacco over 80,000
premature deaths alcohol about 28,000
opiates reached all-time high last year
of nearly 18,000 at 1,800 sorry
and then cocaine paracetamol and feta
mean ecstasy so the big killers are
tobacco some economists say that tobacco
deaths are a matter their core what they
call good deaths because people who
smoke pay a lot of tax during their
lifetime and then they die before they
can draw their pensions so actually they
their net contributors to the economy
whereas alcohol deaths are a must and
more spread out across the age range and
they do have a very powerful impact on
young people and their opiates for the
third so these are the three big killers
and you might have think that those
would be the drugs we wanted to focus
most of our attention on but in fact
largely the hysteria that you read about
drugs in the newspaper in the media is
focused on drugs there on the right hand
side ecstasy in cannabis etc which have
very low levels of harm
and one of the most remarkable studies I
was involved with was this one which was
published about ten years ago now in The
Lancet and it was the most systematic
analysis of drug harms it had never been
done we determined that there were 16
different arms of drugs and we took
these 20 drugs and scaled them on these
16 homes nine of the harms are the harm
to the user and seven of the harms are
harms to society and the harms of the
user are scaled as according to the blue
bars and harm to society as the red bar
and you can see that when you put the
two together alcohol is at the top of
the list because alcohol has such
enormous impact on other people
alcohol damage is almost every single
family this country through either the
economic costs or leap the child beers
the damage and the violence in families
or the road traffic accidents etc that
alcohol produces it's not the most
harmful drug to the user that is to the
right of alcohol you see heroin crack
cocaine crystal meth they're more a
harmful to the user but there must less
widely used so it's that it's a fact
that up to about 80 percent of adults
use alcohol it makes alcohol the most
harmful drug and is a very important
consideration because we do want to try
to minimize harms and alcohol should be
the drug that we really focus our
attention on but as I say it's
eliminated from misuse of drugs acting
it's avoided most politicians will avoid
trying to do something about alcohol
one of the things we discovered when we
finished this piece of work was it to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas